vidon sayed emmanuel macron ont tenu un
point presse comme on pouvait s'y
attendre la crise libyenne a monopolisé
une partie des échanges avec les
journalistes et des discours mais en
préambule emmanuel macron réitéré tout
son soutien envers la tunisie notamment
économiques
un prêt de 350 millions d'euros va être
consentis dans le cadre d'un accord plus
global de 1,7 milliard d'euros pour
soutenir les secteurs de la santé de la
formation et de la jeunesse notamment
et concernant la crise libyenne les deux
pays semblent parfaitement alignés ils
ne souhaitent pas d'ingérence étrangère
et emmanuel macron a tenu des propos
très durs envers la turquie qui
l'accusent de mener un jeu dangereux
d'ailleurs le président français a
récité cette expression qui avait fait
beaucoup jaser à l'époque un la mort
cérébrale de l'otan en prenant pour
exemple le jeu mené par la turquie je
propose d'écouter ses commentaires la
france et la tunisie demande ensemble
que les belligérants cessent le feu et
tiennent leurs engagements de reprendre
la négociation engagée dans le cadre des
nations unies en vue de restaurer la
sécurité de tous de procéder à la
réunification des institutions libyennes
et d'engager la reconstruction au
bénéfice de tous les libyens
c'est un chemin difficile qui nécessite
que chacun fasse preuve de
responsabilité que cessent les
ingérences étrangères
les actes unilatéraux de ceux qui
prétendent gagner de nouvelles positions
à la faveur de la guerre j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire très clairement au
président erdogan
je considère aujourd'hui que la turquie
joue en libye
un jeu dangereux et contrevient à tous
ses engagements pris lors de la
conférence de berlin
c'est le même discours que j'ai tenu cet
après-midi lors de l' échange que j'ai
pu avoir avec le président trump car il
en va de l'intérêt de la libye de ses
voisins de toute la région mais
également de l'europe
le président tunisien a tenu un discours
plus générale plus théorique il a bien
entendu parler de la construction
d'hôpitaux qui allait se faire grâce au
soutien de la france même d'une ligne de
tgv mais il a évoqué les idées nouvelles
qui avaient cours aujourd'hui et des
nouveaux mécanismes de collaboration
politique qu'il comptait mettre en place
avec emmanuel macron mais encore une
fois au moment des questions des
journalistes la question de la crise
libyenne est revenu au centre des
discussions alors je vous propose
d'écouter key sayyed à ce sujet j'ai
appris que les dirigeants de tribus
rédige une constitution pour la libye et
une constitution similaire à celle là
qui avait été adoptée en afghanistan en
2002 lors de la réunion de la loya jirga
donc les chefs de tribu et afghans que
cela soit une étape pas le but final
mais une étape une étape transitoire
pour passer à la paix et à ce qui sera
décidé par les libyens eux mêmes pour le
sans ingérence extérieure quelle qu'elle
soit
aucun président tunisien qui souhaite
que la libye trouvent ces solutions
politiques par elles mêmes sans
ingérence étrangère
les deux présidents semblent totalement
alignée sur une vision du
multilatéralisme
ils n'ont pas hésité d'ailleurs à
évoquer le destin commun liant la
tunisie et la france